It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在正是盛花期，我的业务规模迅速扩大。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有顶级优先数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使蜂巢喧闹，我的连接依然强劲。此外，无限流量套餐起价仅为 35 美元/月。这可是一个不会常驻的优惠。今天就来探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐吧。需加收税费和政府规费。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Never kept a diary? For many people, journaling is a lifetime habit. Others may turn to it in moments of stress or during major life transitions. But in fact, psychologist research suggests that we all might want to consider occasionally writing about our lives, even those of us who don't consider ourselves writers. That's because researchers have found that expressive writing can improve people's mental and even their physical health and can help us work through challenges in our lives. Today we're going to talk about why that is. We're also going to talk about the power of words more generally
Google Fi Wireless 在网络高使用率期间不会遭受数据流量降速。从未写过日记？对许多人来说，写日记是一种终生的习惯。其他人可能会在压力时刻或人生重大转折期转向它。但事实上，心理学研究表明，我们所有人都或许应该考虑偶尔写写自己的生活，即使是我们当中那些不觉得自己是作家的人。这是因为研究人员发现，表达性写作可以改善人们的精神甚至身体健康，并能帮助我们度过生活中的挑战。今天我们将讨论其中的原因。我们还将更广泛地讨论文字的力量
and about how the words we use can offer insights into our emotions, motivations, and personality. So why does writing about our lives improve our mental health? Do you have to write every day to see these effects? Does it matter how a person writes? Are there guidelines to follow if you want to try it? And how does language connect to emotions, motivations, and personality? What do the words we use tell us about ourselves and each other? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association
以及我们使用的词语如何让我们深入了解自己的情绪、动机和人格。那么，为什么写下我们的生活能改善我们的心理健康呢？你必须每天写作才能看到这些效果吗？一个人的写作方式重要吗？如果你想尝试，有什么指南可以遵循吗？语言与情绪、动机和人格是如何联系的？我们使用的词语向我们揭示了关于我们自己和彼此的什么信息？欢迎收听“心理学对话”（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客
that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. James Pena Baker, a professor emeritus of psychology at the University of Texas at Austin. He conducted pioneering research on expressive writing in the 1980s and 90s. Since then, he's focused on natural language use and how language, personality, and social behavior interact. Dr. Pennybaker is the author or editor of more than 300 articles and 12 books, including expressive writing, words that heal, and The Secret Life of Pronouns, What Our Words Say About Us. He has received numerous awards for teaching and research, including the 2016 APA Award for Distinguished Applications of Psychology.
它探讨了心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是德克萨斯大学奥斯汀分校心理学荣休教授詹姆斯·佩内贝克（Dr. James Pennebaker）。他在20世纪80年代和90年代对表达性写作进行了开创性的研究。从那时起，他一直专注于自然语言的使用，以及语言、人格和社交行为是如何相互作用的。佩内贝克博士是300多篇文章和12本书的作者或编辑，其中包括《表达性写作：疗愈之语》（Expressive Writing: Words That Heal）和《代词的秘密生活：我们的词语说明了什么》（The Secret Life of Pronouns: What Our Words Say About Us）。他因教学和研究获得了众多奖项，包括2016年APA心理学杰出应用奖。
Dr. Penne Baker, thanks for joining me. It's great to be here. Thank you. Let's start with your research on expressive writing. You're a social psychologist by training, not a clinical psychologist. So how did you get started studying what eventually became recognized as this powerful therapeutic technique? Well, this is actually the story of my life. I've never really planned to go in any particular direction, just letting interesting things
佩内贝克博士，谢谢你接受我的采访。很高兴来到这里。谢谢。让我们从你关于表达性写作的研究开始。你受过训练是一名社会心理学家，而不是临床心理学家。那么你是如何开始研究后来被认可为这种强大的治疗技术的呢？嗯，这其实就是我的人生故事。我从来没有真正计划过朝任何特定的方向发展，只是让有趣的事情
fall in my lap. early in my career I was interested in mind-body issues. Why do people to get sick? How do you know if you're sick? And I was working on what became an early book called the Psychology Physical Symptoms, and I was thinking, you know, I should do a questionnaire just to get a sense of what kind of people, what kind of personalities, what kind of life experiences might be related to people reporting physical symptoms. And I came up with this giant questionnaire working with students.
落在我头上。在我职业生涯的早期，我对身心问题很感兴趣。为什么人们会生病？你怎么知道自己是否生病了？我当时在写一本后来成为早期书的作品，叫做《身体症状心理学》，我在想，你知道，我应该做一个问卷调查，只是为了了解什么样的人、什么样的性格、什么样的生活经历可能与人们报告身体症状有关。于是我与学生们合作，想出了这份巨大的问卷。
and we put on questions that things that sounded interesting. They didn't have any theoretical basis. We asked about people's diet, how they got along with their parents. And one of the students I was working with says, how about this one? Prior to the age of 17, did you ever have a traumatic sexual experience? And I thought, yeah, that's an interesting question. You know, that's certainly nothing, nobody ever asked that question back in the early 80s. That one question ended up being one of the most powerful predictor of physical symptoms
我们在上面添加了听起来很有趣的问题。它们没有任何理论基础。我们询问了人们的饮食情况、他们与父母的相处方式。我合作的一个学生说：“这个怎么样？在17岁之前，你是否有过创伤性的性经历？”我想，是的，这是一个有趣的问题。你知道，这绝对是80年代初没有人问过的问题。这一个问题最终成为身体症状最有力的预测指标之一
in health. And I later did this with a national sample. And again, people who endorsed that items were more likely to have been hospitalized for any cause in the previous years. It was related to colds, flus, cancer, high blood pressure, you name it. And I became fascinated. What is it about a traumatic sexual experience? And as I started to do more studies, I discovered.
与健康有关。我后来用全国样本做了这个研究。同样，赞同该项目的个体在过去几年中因各种原因住院的可能性更高。它与感冒、流感、癌症、高血压等各种疾病有关。我着迷了。创伤性性经历到底是怎么回事？随着我开始做更多的研究，我发现
it wasn't just a traumatic sexual experience. It was having any kind of traumatic experience that people kept secrets. Now, we had known forever that traumas were bad for physical health. That wasn't news. But having a trauma of any kind in keeping it secret really increased the toxicity of that trauma. In other words, secrets in and of themselves were toxic. And this made me wonder, if secrets are so bad, what if we brought people in the laboratory and had them talk about them or that turned out to be way too complex? How about we just had them write about it? And that was kind of the birth of expressive writing. So what is it about expressive writing that helps people? And how is it different from other types of writing, for example, just writing letters, essays,
这不仅仅是创伤性的性经历。而是经历过人们保守秘密的任何类型的创伤。现在，我们一直都知道创伤对身体健康有害。这不是什么新鲜事。但经历任何形式的创伤并将其保密，确实增加了该创伤的毒性。换句话说，秘密本身就是有毒的。这让我觉得奇怪，如果秘密这么糟糕，如果我们把人们带到实验室让他们谈论这些秘密会怎么样？事实证明这太复杂了。如果我们只是让他们写下来呢？这可以说是表达性写作的诞生。那么，表达性写作究竟是如何帮助人们的呢？它与其它类型的写作有何不同，例如仅仅写信、文章、
or even lists that we write to keep ourselves organized? We'll get into those questions because those questions are actually much deeper than you might expect. The quick answer is there, many of these approaches probably are just about as effective. What I did with that first study, I had no idea of should I have people right once or how many times should I have them right? And the first studies were all done with college students. I decided it would make sense to have people write maybe three or four times. And I needed to do an experiment in an efficient way. And so I would have people, they were randomly assigned by flip of the coin to either write about a traumatic experience for four days or about superficial topics for four days. And I needed to
甚至是我们为了保持条理而写的清单？我们会深入探讨这些问题，因为这些问题实际上比你想象的要深奥得多。简单的回答是，其中许多方法可能同样有效。在做第一项研究时，我根本不知道是让人写一次还是应该让他们写多少次？最初的研究都是在大学生中进行的。我决定让人写个三四次是有道理的。我需要以一种高效的方式做一个实验。因此，我让人们通过抛硬币随机分配，连续四天写一段创伤经历，或者连续四天写一些肤浅的话题。我需要
have them write it in a laboratory at the university. And this study was done at Southern Methodist University in Dallas. And I needed enough rooms. And I wanted to line everybody up essentially and essentially have somebody come at, you know, four in the afternoon, four 10, 420, et cetera, and just line them up and run all 50 or so people in an afternoon. And to do that, I needed a lot of rooms. And I was able to get enough rooms to run for four hours. And I had a lot of people helping me. And we could only get those rooms for a week, which was really four days, Monday through Thursday.
让他们在大学的实验室里写。这项研究是在达拉斯的南方卫理公会大学进行的。我需要足够的房间。我想基本上把每个人排好队，基本上让某人在下午4点、4点10分、4点20分等时间来，然后把他们排好队，在一个下午运行大约50个人。为了做到这一点，我需要很多房间。我能够获得足够的房间运行四个小时。我有很多帮手。我们只能把那些房间保留一个星期，实际上是四天，从星期一到星期四。
And just doing the arithmetic that meant that everyone could write in that first study, I believe it was 15 minutes, and they wrote for four days because that's all we could get the times. And it had to be after all classes had finished. And so all these practical considerations. And that first study was powerful because those people who were asked to write about upsetting experiences ended up going to the student health center at about half the rates of. of people in our controls. So there was no great theory of how much they should write. There was no great foresight in terms of what they should write about. And that was the other issue.
通过简单的算术，这意味着在第一项研究中，每个人都可以写作，我相信是15分钟，他们连续写了四天，因为那是我们能获得时间的全部。而且必须在所有课程结束后进行。因此，所有这些实际的考量。第一项研究之所以有力量，是因为那些被要求写令人不安经历的人，去学生健康中心的比率大约是……控制组人员的一半。因此，对于他们应该写多少，并没有伟大的理论。在他们应该写什么方面也没有深谋远虑。这就是另一个问题。
What should I have them write about? Well, I didn't know. So I thought, you know, I'll have them write about a really traumatic experience that they'd had. And actually, here were the first instructions that I gave. For the next four days, what I'd like to have you do is to really let go. and explore your deepest thoughts and feelings about the most upsetting or traumatic experience of your entire life. I really want you to let go.
我应该让他们写什么？嗯，我不知道。所以我想，你知道，我会让他们写他们经历过的一次真正的创伤经历。事实上，我给出的第一条指令是：在接下来的四天里，我想让你做的是真正地释放，并探索你对一生中最令人不安或最具创伤性的经历的最深层思想和感受。我真的想让你释放。
As you write, I want you to write continuously. Don't worry about spelling or grammar or anything like that. And in your writing, you might write about how it relates to other issues in your life, maybe related to your childhood, maybe related to school, or how it could be related to your friendships, or who you'd like to be in the future or who you've been in the past, or who you are now. And you can write about the same traumatic experience all four days, or you can write something different each day. That's entirely up to you. And in fact, many people have never had a trauma, but all of us have had major stressors or conflicts. And you can write about those as well.
在你写作时，我希望你连续书写。不要担心拼写或语法或诸如此类的事情。在你的写作中，你可能会写它与你生活中的其他问题的关系，也许与你的童年有关，也许与学校有关，或者它如何与你的友情有关，或者你想成为未来的人，或者你过去的人，或者你现在的人。你可以连续四天写同一个创伤经历，或者每天写不同的东西。这完全取决于你。事实上，许多人从未经历过创伤，但我们所有人都经历过重大的压力源或冲突。你也可以写那些。
And ideally, I'd like to have you focus on something that you haven't talked to other people about much. So for the next four days, I really want you to really let go and write. So that was the instruction. And then people who were assigned to the control condition were asked to write about superficial topics. Initially, we had them write about things like the shoes they were wearing or their dorm room or something like that. But then later, I became fascinated with time management. I've always been dismissive of time management. To me, I think that's kind of training for obsessive compulsive disorder. In any case, what I did was after the first couple of studies, in the control condition, I'd ask people how they use their time.
理想情况下，我希望你专注于那些你没有和别人多谈论的事情。所以在接下来的四天里，我真的希望你能够真正释放并写作。这就是指令。然后，被分配到控制组的被试被要求写一些肤浅的话题。最初，我们让他们写一些诸如他们穿着的鞋子或他们的宿舍之类的东西。但后来，我对时间管理着迷了。我一直对时间管理不屑一顾。在我看来，这有点像强迫症的训练。无论如何，我所做的是在前几项研究之后，在控制组中，我问人们如何利用他们的时间。
What did you do during the last 24 hours? What do you plan to do during the next 24 hours? What did you do last week, et cetera? And having them focus on details. And I'm pleased to say that never was associated with any improvements in health or anything else. So, but everybody thought it was, they thought that, well, it's time management. It must be good. But the point, with this was in those first studies, we were focusing on traumas. And then I started having people write about different topics. One of my next studies was having people not writing about the most traumatic experience of their lives, but I got college freshmen who were just starting college, and I would have them write about their deepest thoughts and feelings about coming to college
你在过去24小时里做了什么？你计划在接下来的24小时里做什么？你上周做了什么，等等？让他们专注于细节。我很高兴地说，这从未与健康状况的改善或任何其他事情联系在一起。所以，但每个人都这么认为，他们认为，嗯，这是时间管理。它一定很好。但关键是，在最初的那些研究中，我们专注于创伤。然后我开始让人们写不同的主题。我的下一项研究之一不是让人们写他们一生中最具创伤性的经历，而是找刚开始上大学的大一新生，让他们写下他们对来到大学的最深层的思想和感受
with the same general instructions, tie this into other experiences. And we got the same effects. And then we started doing more and more studies with people who got laid off from their jobs or you name it. It seemed in those first few years we started doing more and more studies, having people write about anything. And those first studies, we had them right for the first one, I think it was four days, 15 minutes a day. The second study, I think was 20 minutes a day for four days. And then their next study was three days. And that study after that was five days. And sometimes it would be as little as 10 minutes, sometimes as long as 30 minutes.
带有相同的通用指令，将此与其它经历联系起来。我们得到了相同的效果。然后我们开始对那些被公司解雇的人等进行越来越多的研究。在最初的几年里，我们似乎开始做越来越多的研究，让人们写任何东西。在最初的研究中，我们让他们写第一个，我想是四天，一天15分钟。第二项研究，我想是连续四天，一天20分钟。然后他们的下一项研究是三天。那之后的那个研究是五天。有时只有10分钟，有时长达30分钟。
And they all got similar effects. So that ended up being kind of the basis of this. And it's ironic that there have now been over 2,000 studies published on expressive writing. I'm astounded by this. I can't even keep up with the literature. I was recently looking online with Google Scholar. how many papers have been published on expressive writing in the last year. And it's about 200.
他们的效果都差不多。所以这最终成为了这方面的基础。具有讽刺意味的是，现在已经发表了超过 2000 项关于表达性写作的研究。对此我感到震惊。我甚至无法跟上文献的速度。我最近在谷歌学术（Google Scholar）上在线查阅了过去一年发表了多少关于表达性写作的论文。大约有 200 篇。
It's really quite surprising. Wow. And some of the studies work. Some of them don't work. I mean, it's not a giant effect. But what's been interesting is some people will have individuals write for two days, three days, four days, five days. Some will have them write once a week for four weeks. Sometimes they'll have them write several times in one day.
这真的很令人惊讶。哇。而且有些研究管用。有些不管用。我的意思是，这不是一个巨大的效应。但有趣的是，有些人会让个人写两天、三天、四天、五天。有些人会让她们连续四周每周写一次。有时他们会让她们在一天内写好几次。
Sometimes they'll have them write 20 minutes, 10 minutes. There's even been a couple of studies where people write just two minutes each time. And again, they all seem to work. Is there a greater effect for the deeper feelings? Is that what you're seeing? So in addition to secret, it's something that is really heartfelt and deep inside? I think the heartfelt deep inside is true with all of these. And even if you write for two minutes, what's interesting is,
有时他们会让她们写 20 分钟、10 分钟。甚至还有几项研究中，人们每次只写两分钟。同样，它们似乎都管用。更深的情感会有更大的效果吗？这就是你所看到的吗？因此，除了秘密，它是真正发自内心的和内心深处的东西吗？我认为发自内心的内心深处适用于所有这些。即使你只写两分钟，有趣的是，
There's a false sense that, oh, you're only writing for two minutes four times. That's only eight minutes. It can't possibly work. Well, the reality is you're writing for those two minutes, but you're thinking about it. You leave the lab and you start pondering it and you might talk to somebody about it. You live with that experience over the course of the study. And so look how most people are, and I'm one of these most people's. You know, I never was a dedicated writer, and I'm still not a dedicated writer.
有一种错误的观念，哦，你四次加起来只写了两分钟。那只有八分钟。这根本不可能起作用。嗯，现实是你只写了那两分钟，但你在思考它。你离开实验室，开始琢磨它，你可能会和某人谈论它。在研究的过程中，你与那种经历共同生活。所以看看大多数人是怎么样的，而我就是这些大多数人中的一员。你知道，我从来都不是一个专注的作家，我到现在也不是一个专注的作家。
I write when I need to. And it used to be if I was upset about something, I had had a fight with my wife, or there'd been conflict at work or whatever. What I would do is I would not talk about it. You know, I'd walk down the street and I'd start thinking about it. And then I said, I should have said this. and then I'll think about something else. And then I think, well, I should write about this. No, it'll just make me think about it too much, which of course is stupid because I've already
我在需要的时候写作。过去，如果我对某事感到心烦意乱，我和妻子吵过架，或者工作上有冲突什么的。我会做的是，我不会谈论它。你知道，我走在街上，我开始思考它。然后我说，我本应该这么说的。然后我会去想别的事情。然后我想，嗯，我应该写下来。不，这只会让我过多地思考它，当然这很愚蠢，因为我已经
thinking about it too much. Right, right. And so getting people to actually sit down and confront it and to write it, you don't have to write a lot, but you have to, first of all, just acknowledge it and put it into words. And that was really for me, the breakthrough. Do people have to write on a regular basis to see a really significant effect? Like, do I have to write something every day to really experience the benefits? Oh, my God, no.
想得太多了。对，对。所以让人们真正坐下来面对它并把它写下来，你不必写很多，但你必须首先承认它并把它诉诸文字。对我来说，这真的是一个突破。人们必须定期写作才能看到真正显著的效果吗？比如，我必须每天写点东西才能真正体验到好处吗？天哪，不。
To give you an example, I write maybe two or three times a year, you know, when something miserable is going on. You know, when I hear about journaling and writing every day, I just get nervous about it. I would hate that because I use writing when I'm dealing with something that is ugly, unpleasant, painful. And if life is going well, why in the world do I want to introspect it? You know, I want to enjoy life when it's here. And when there's bad things, writing for me helps me get through them. And so I view it almost as I've often thought of it as an antibiotic.
举个例子，我一年大概写两三次，你知道，当有什么痛苦的事情发生的时候。你知道，当我听到关于写日记和每天写作时，我就会感到紧张。我会讨厌那样，因为当我处理一些丑陋的、不愉快的、痛苦的事情时，我就会使用写作。如果生活进展顺利，我为什么要在世界上内省它呢？你知道，当它存在时，我想享受生活。当有坏事发生时，写作可以帮助我度过难关。所以我几乎认为它就像抗生素。
You know, you have all these bad things going on, and then you use this method to get past it. And then next time something bad happens, I'll use writing again. Is there a difference between writing something by hand or writing on a computer or what about talking to a speech to text program? Any differences there? There have been now a large number of studies comparing them, and I'd have to say that on average, there's no difference. If you stand back and you squint at the data, you can see a weak effect that writing by hand might work a little bit better, but my colleagues don't really acknowledge the squint test.
你知道，你身边发生了很多糟糕的事情，然后你用这种方法度过难关。下次再有坏事发生时，我会再次使用写作。手写和在电脑上写有什么区别？或者使用语音转文字程序怎么样？有什么区别吗？现在已经有大量研究对它们进行了比较，我不得不说，平均而言，没有什么区别。如果你退后一步，眯起眼睛看数据，你可以看到一个微弱的效应，手写可能会稍微好一点，但我的同事并不真正承认眯眼测试。
So it probably doesn't matter. My recommendation is to do what you're most comfortable with. And I've experimented with, and I've actually tested this with people in workshops, having people write using finger writing, where you just, with your finger, write in the air about an upsetting experience. I invented this years ago when my wife and I were on a vacation somewhere, and we'd had a significant disagreement about something. I got up in the middle of the night, and I was thinking, I should write, but if I turn on the lights, it'll wake her up. And so I just sat there. writing in the air and I thought, ooh, this works. And it actually does. So I think the real art is
所以这可能无关紧要。我的建议是做你觉得最舒服的事。我做过实验，并且实际上在工作坊中用人们进行了测试，让人们用手指书写，你只需用手指在空中写下令人不安的经历。多年前，我和妻子在某个地方度假时，我发明了这种方法，我们对某事产生了分歧。我在半夜醒来，心想，我应该写下来，但如果我开灯，会吵醒她。所以我只是坐在那里。在空中写作，我想，哦，这管用。它确实管用。所以我觉得真正的艺术在于
translating an emotional experience into words. And by doing that, that changes the way that experience is organized in the brain and it slows down your thinking process. And it also forces structure in creating a story. In other words, when you're writing, you have to use, use a complete sentence. And if you write a complete sentence, your next sentence has to be related to that sentence you just finished. So it's all part of putting together complex emotional topics. So it sounds like a really great tool. Would you say it could substitute for therapy or should you do expressive writing in conjunction with therapy? Might that supercharge the effect that you're getting? So, of course, if I'm talking on an APA podcast and say,
将情绪体验转化为文字。通过这样做，改变了该体验在大脑中的组织方式，并减慢了你的思考过程。它还迫使在创作故事时形成结构。换句话说，当你写作时，你必须使用一个完整的句子。如果你写了一个完整的句子，你的下一句必须与你刚完成的那句话相关。所以这一切都是为了把复杂的情感话题拼凑在一起。听起来这真是一个很棒的工具。你会说它可以替代治疗吗？或者你应该将表达性写作与治疗结合起来使用？这可能会超级激发你所获得的效果吗？所以，当然，如果我在一个 APA 的播客上说，
that this could take the place of therapy, I would be drummed out of the field. I do think that writing is a powerful method that anybody can use any time and it's free. And if you write a few times, you don't feel so you're getting any better, I think therapy is a really good alternative or jogging or talking to a friend. I also think writing works wonderfully in conjunction with therapy. And I would bet that a very high percentage of therapists actually use some form of writing in conjunction with therapy. And I've even recommended the therapist to, if they would like to speed up the effectiveness of a therapeutic session, is when the person shows up to, to me, meet with you. And they typically are in the waiting room for five or ten minutes. Put them in a
这可以取代治疗，我会被赶出这个领域。我确实认为写作是一种任何人都可以随时使用的强大方法，而且它是免费的。如果你写了几次，觉得并没有什么改善，我认为治疗是一个非常好的选择，或者慢跑，或者和朋友交谈。我也认为写作与治疗结合使用效果极佳。我敢打赌，很大一部分治疗师实际上在治疗中使用了某种形式的写作。我甚至向治疗师推荐过，如果他们想加快治疗环节的当事人效果，当这个人出现并与你见面时。他们通常在候诊室待五到十分钟。把他们放在一个
room and have them right for five or ten minutes and then bring them into the therapeutic session. And when my friends have tried that, they've been impressed that, you know, that the people are much more focused on what they want to talk about. They have a better sense of the issues. And it makes a therapy go, I think, more efficiently. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill four-burner gas grill on special buy for only $199 and entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $49. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies, price invalid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See homedipo.com
房间里，让他们写五到十分钟，然后把他们带进治疗环节。当我的朋友们尝试了这一点时，他们印象深刻，你知道，人们更专注于他们想谈论的事情。他们对问题有了更好的理解。我认为这使治疗进行得更有效率。你的夏天现在就开始了，家得宝（The Home Depot）阵亡将士纪念日大促销火热进行中。是时候点燃夏日烧烤了，Next Grill 四燃烧器燃气烤炉特价仅售 199 美元，更有 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐饮桌椅组合仅售 49 美元，让你整个季节尽情招待亲朋。这个阵亡将士纪念日，来家得宝享受低价保证。数量有限，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，不适用情况请参阅详情，访问 homedepot.com
slash price match for details. Let's change gears now and talk for a minute about you more. recent work, which is on language analysis and what we can learn about people from studying their word use. How did you move from expressive writing into this work? How are they connected if they are? They are intimately connected. You know, I was doing these first studies on expressive writing. We're now into the mid-1990s.
斜杠价格匹配（slash price match）。现在让我们换个话题，花一分钟聊聊你最近的工作，也就是关于语言分析以及我们通过研究人们的词汇使用可以对他们了解多少。你是如何从表达性写作过渡到这项工作的？它们是如何联系的（如果它们有联系的话）？它们是紧密相连的。你知道，我当时正在做关于表达性写作的这些初步研究。我们现在已经进入了 20世纪90年代中期。
And I was trying to understand who benefited from writing. You know, people didn't always benefit from writing. the stories that people were writing were unbelievably powerful. And I was curious, is there some way of writing that may be more effective than others? And so I initially was able to get a large number of graduate students in the counseling program and have them read these essays and to evaluate them in terms of all these dimensions, you know, how self-reflective is this first? person, how effective do you think writing wasn't changing them? To what degree did they find some kind of meaning?
我当时试图了解谁从写作中受益。你知道，人们并不总是从写作中受益。人们写的故事简直太强大了。我很好奇，有没有某种写作方式可能比其他方式更有效？所以我最初能够让咨询项目的大量研究生阅读这些文章，并根据所有这些维度对它们进行评估，你知道，第一人称的自我反省程度如何，你认为写作在改变他们方面有多有效？他们在多大程度上找到某种意义？
How emotional were they, et cetera, et cetera. And what I discovered was that having people, first of all, just read these traumatic stories. And people, by the way, did write really traumatic events that you and I and everybody listened to this. If you read them, you would agree that these were really upsetting experiences. What we discovered was that people who were reading these stories got depressed reading them because they were so upsetting. And also the judges who were reading them didn't agree on any of the ratings. In other words, here we were essentially having to do many therapy with our raters, and their ratings were not internally consistent or valid.
他们的情绪化程度如何，等等。我发现的是，首先，让人们阅读这些创伤故事。顺便说一句，人们确实写了你和我以及所有听这个节目的人都会经历的真正创伤事件。如果你读了它们，你会同意这些确实是令人不安的经历。我们发现的是，阅读这些故事的人在阅读时变得沮丧，因为它们太令人不安了。而且阅读它们的评审在任何评分上都无法达成一致。换句话说，我们基本上不得不对我们的评估员进行微型治疗，而且他们的评分在内部既不一致也不有效。
And so here was a, oh, and it was really slow and expensive. This is not a way to build a career if you're trying to understand writing. So I thought, you know, I had taken a little computer science in college. And I had a sense of how you could write a computer program that could analyze it. And by the way, I looked to see if there were any computer programs that existed at the time. And there weren't. I talked to experts all over the country, and I told them what I was looking for, and they all agreed it was an interesting project, but they didn't know who could be helpful. So, by the way, I should say about four years after I had finished writing this computer program with my students, I discovered that there, in fact, had been a really wonderful computer program written by a group out of Harvard.
所以这是一个，哦，而且它真的很慢很贵。如果你想了解写作，这不是建立职业生涯的方法。所以我想，你知道，我在大学里学过一点计算机科学。我有一种感觉，你可以编写一个计算机程序来分析它。顺便说一句，我查了一下当时是否存在任何计算机程序。结果并没有。我咨询了全国各地的专家，我告诉他们我在找什么，他们都认为这是一个有趣的项目，但他们不知道谁能帮上忙。顺便说一句，我应该说，在我与学生一起完成这个计算机程序编写工作大约四年后，我发现，事实上，哈佛大学的一个小组在
Harvard in the 1960s, which was that had preceded me by quite a bit, it wouldn't have worked for me at the time because it was built for a giant mainframe computer. But in any case, unfortunately, I had a graduate student in my lab at the time. This was about 1992, 93, Martha Francis, whose undergraduate degree had been in computer science. And she had taken some years off and had come back to graduate school in social psychology. and you know I sat with her I said Martha I've got a great idea for an experiment or for a computer program and you know I think it should be pretty simple I can't believe it'll take more than two or three weeks to write we worked on it and that two to three weeks kind of expanded you know expanded two or three years but you know
20世纪60年代在哈佛编写了一个非常棒的计算机程序，它比我早了很多，当时对我来说行不通，因为它是为巨型大型机计算机构建的。但无论如何，不幸的是，我当时实验室里有一位研究生。这大概是 1992、93 年左右，玛莎·弗朗西斯（Martha Francis），她的本科学位是计算机科学。她休息了几年，然后回到社会心理学读研究生。你知道，我坐在她旁边，我说：“玛莎，我有一个关于实验或计算机程序的绝妙想法，你知道，我认为它应该很简单，我简直不敢相信写它需要两三个星期以上。”我们为此努力了，而那两三到三个星期有点扩展了，你知道，扩展了两三年，但你知道，
such as the nature of science and it was it wasn't the program itself that took so long It was how do, you know, if you're going to tell a computer to look for anger words, you have to tell the computer what are anger words to look for. And so we had to make all of these dictionaries of words. And we started off with the way everybody starts something like this, looking for emotions, you know, anger, happiness, guilt, sadness, etc. And then we also wanted some, you know, therapy-related words, you know, words like self-reflection, inside, causal thinking, words like because, cause effect, and other dimensions that psychologists
这就是科学的本质。花那么长时间的不是程序本身，而是如何，你知道的，如果你要告诉计算机寻找愤怒的词，你必须告诉计算机要寻找什么样的愤怒词。所以我们不得不制作所有这些词典。我们以每个人开始这类事情的方式开始，寻找情绪，你知道，愤怒、快乐、内疚、悲伤等。然后我们还想要一些，你知道的，与治疗相关的词，你知道，诸如自我反思、洞察、因果思维之类的词，诸如因为、因果关系等词，以及心理学家感兴趣的其他维度。
were interested in. And then as long as we're at it, we might as well do parts of speech, because those don't require a lot of work to figure out. So, you know, articles and prepositions and pronouns and so forth. So that's how we put this computer program together. It was called, we called it Linguistic Inquiry and Word Count, L-I-W-C. And, I should say I had been given a lot of flack because earlier in my career I'd come up with names of scales that were cute. And cute was not viewed as science. Not too serious. Exactly.
然后既然我们正在做，我们不妨也做词性，因为那些不需要花太多功夫去弄清楚。所以，你知道，冠词、介词、代词等等。这就是我们把这个计算机程序拼凑在一起的方式。它被称为，我们称之为“语言调查与字数统计”（Linguistic Inquiry and Word Count），简称 LIWC。而且，我应该说，我遭到了很多批评，因为在我职业生涯的早期，我想出了一些很可爱的量表名称。而可爱并不被视为科学。不太严肃。完全正确。
Linguistic inquiry and word count, L-I-W-C, now that's serious. But then we called the computer program Luke. So if you ever hear the word Luke, it's either a book of the Bible or it's by computer program. In any case, the Luke program ended up being a marvelous program. And it's now in its maybe sixth or seventh edition. And the newest version is a real machine. But what it allowed us to do was to go through and go into any expressive writing study and look at the essays people have written.
语言调查和字数统计，LIWC，现在这很严肃。但后来我们把这个计算机程序叫做“卢克”（Luke）。所以如果你听到“卢克”这个词，它要么是《圣经》中的一本书，要么是我的计算机程序。无论如何，“卢克”程序最终是一个了不起的程序。它现在可能已经出到第六版或第七版了。最新版本是一个真正的机器。但它允许我们做的是，深入任何表达性写作研究并查看人们写文章。
And we started to see that there were certain features that predicted improvement. So if a person, ironically, if a person's writing about a trauma, the more they're able to use positive emotion words, the more likely they are to benefit. And it's kind of ironic. So if they say they're not happy, nobody cares about them, they feel no love from anybody, those words care, loves, things like that are positive, emotion words. So even if they're negating those positive emotion words, they're better off than if they don't use positive emotion words. In other words, if I say I'm not happy, I'm still thinking along that dimension of happiness. If I say I'm sad, I'm not thinking about happiness as the altars did. So that was one of the first surprising things. The more powerful effect,
我们开始看到有一些特定的特征可以预测改善。因此，如果一个人，具有讽刺意味的是，如果一个人在写关于创伤的文章，他们越能使用积极的情绪词，他们就越有可能受益。这有点讽刺。因此，如果他们说他们不快乐，没有人关心他们，他们觉得没有来自任何人的爱，那些关心、爱之类的词是积极的情绪词。因此，即使他们否定了这些积极的情绪词，也比他们不使用积极的情绪词要好。换句话说，如果我说我不快乐，我仍然在沿着快乐的维度思考。如果我说我很悲伤，我并没有像其他人那样把快乐当作圣坛。所以这是第一个令人惊讶的事情。更强大的效果，
however, were cognitive words. Early on, we are focusing on a number of types, but One were causal words because cause effect, reason, rationale. And another type were what we called insight words, understand, realize, no, meaning, words such as that. And what we discovered was the more that people use those words over the course of their writing, the more they improve. That is, the more they were trying to understand what was going on, the more they were trying to construct a story, the more likely they. word of benefit. Some later studies, we discovered some other issues as well. Pronouns, for example, are really powerful. As a social psychologist, I should have picked up on this immediately, but when I'm using eye words, by definition, when I say, I'm feeling so-and-so, my use of the word
然而，是认知词。早期，我们关注多种类型，但其中一种是因果词，因为有因果、原因、理由。另一种类型是我们所谓的洞察词，理解、意识到、知道、意义，诸如此类的词。我们发现的是，在写作过程中，人们使用这些词越多，他们的改善就越大。也就是说，他们越是试图理解发生了什么，他们越是试图构建一个故事，他们就越有可能。字面上的受益。在后来的研究中，我们还发现了一些其他问题。例如，代词真的很强大。作为一名社会心理学家，我本应该立刻注意到这一点，但当我在使用“我”这个词时，根据定义，当我说，我感觉某某，我对“我”字的使用是对自我的非常短暂的意识。所以“我”字真的很有趣。我们知道。
I is a very brief awareness of self. So eye words are really interesting. We know. know that actually people who are depressed start using eye words at very high rates. And when their depression lifts, eye words drop significantly. And people who are anxious use more eye words. People who are sad. Ironically, we've used this to predict, actually, suicide. We've looked at suicidal poets versus non-suicidal poets. And the two poets don't differ in terms of negative of emotion words. The big difference is suicidal poets use eye words at much higher rates. And again, they're focusing so heavily on self compared to non-suicide. That's really fascinating. Isn't that interesting? Yeah. And what we found was that people who benefited the most from
知道实际上抑郁的人开始以极高的频率使用“我”字。当他们的抑郁消退时，“我”字显著下降。焦虑的人使用更多的“我”字。悲伤的人。具有讽刺意味的是，我们用这个来预测自杀。我们比较了自杀诗人和非自杀诗人。两位诗人在消极情绪词方面没有区别。最大的区别是自杀诗人以高得多的频率使用“我”字。同样，与非自杀者相比，他们过分关注自我。这真的很着迷。是不是很有趣？是的。我们发现，从中受益最多的人
writing would change in their use of pronouns over the course of the three or four writing session. So one time they might use I words at high rates and other times they're using other pronouns, he, she, they, we, and then back to I and then others. And what they're doing is they're changing their perspective. And I think this therapists do this themselves when a client comes in and you ask them what's going on, well, my marriage is a problem. And then they'll say, well, I feel this, I feel this, I feel this, I feel this, I feel this. And the therapist at some point will say, yeah, yeah, yeah. What about the other person?
写作会在三四次写作过程中改变他们对代词的使用。所以有时他们可能会以高频率使用“我”字，而其他时候他们使用其他代词，他、她、他们、我们，然后又回到“我”和其他代词。他们正在做的是改变他们的视角。我认为治疗师自己也会这样做，当来访者进来时，你问他们发生了什么，嗯，我的婚姻有问题。然后他们会说，嗯，我觉得这个，我觉得这个，我觉得这个，我觉得这个，我觉得这个。治疗师在某个时候会说，对，对，对。另一个人呢？
What's going on with the other person? Or if the person comes in, problems with my marriage, yeah, you know, my spouse, it does this, they do this, they do this, they do this. And Sarah will say, yeah, yeah, yeah. But you, how do you feel? Something about yourself. In other words, the therapist is naturally doing what people who benefit from writing do. They're able to go back and forth between self and other.
另一个人怎么了？或者如果这个人进来，我的婚姻有问题，嗯，你知道，我的配偶，它做了这个，他们做了这个，他们做了这个，他们做了这个。萨拉（Sarah）会说，对，对，对。但是你，你感觉怎么样？关于你自己的事。换句话说，治疗师在自然地做那些从写作中受益的人所做的事情。他们能够在自我和他人之间来回切换。
So changing perspective is helpful. That's right. That's right. And people who write the same way all three or four days hardly ever benefit. And in fact, writing about the same story in the same way is really the same as rumination. It's almost a marker that writing is not beneficial. And if you find that you tell the same story over and over again, you're not getting any traction. Yeah, I was just going to ask another word-based question. You have talked about the difference between content words and style words. How are they different? What do we learn about analyzing those words? It's funny. That was what I think the biggest breakthrough I had with the language work.
所以改变视角是有帮助的。没错。没错。那些三四天都以同样方式写作的人几乎从来没有受益过。事实上，以同样的方式写同一个故事实际上和反刍是一样的。这几乎是一个写作无益的标志。如果你发现你一遍又一遍地讲同一个故事，你就会停滞不前。是的，我正要问另一个基于词汇的问题。你讨论过内容词和风格词之间的区别。它们有什么不同？通过分析这些词，我们能学到什么？这很有趣。这就是我认为我在语言工作上取得的最大突破。
When I started doing this, it was just at the creation of the Internet. This was about 1995, 96. And there was this new invention called America Online. And I suspect, Kim, you know about American Online. And I'm guessing many people out there in podcast land won't know it, AOL. AOL was this incredible breakthrough. You got a disc you put on your computer. If you had a modem, it allowed you to connect to the Internet.
当我开始做这个的时候，正值互联网的诞生。大约是 1995、96 年。有一个新发明叫美国在线（America Online）。我猜，金（Kim），你知道美国在线。我猜播客里有很多听众不知道它，AOL。AOL 是一个令人难以置信的突破。你得到一张光盘，把它放进你的电脑。如果你有调制解调器，它允许你连接到互联网。
And what was fascinating was they, AOL had these chat groups. And you could be in these chat groups with people from all over the world. And for somebody like me, it was unbelievable because you could download chats. And what I would do is at night, you know, we put the kids to bed and then I'd go into my study. And I would just go to chat rooms and I'd just download. And sometimes I'd go to chat groups that were predominantly women and others that were predominantly men and so forth. And I started looking at the differences at the beginning between men and women and how they use language. And I had all of these theories that many people probably would share with that I had, that I just assume women would use wee words at higher rate than men.
迷人的是，AOL 有这些聊天群。你可以和来自世界各地的人一起在这些聊天群里。对于像我这样的人来说，这简直是不可思议的，因为你可以下载聊天记录。我常做的是在晚上，你知道，我们把孩子们哄上床，然后我去我的书房。我就去聊天室下载。有时我会去主要是女性的聊天群，有些主要是男性的聊天群等等。我开始观察男女之间在使用语言上的差异，最初我有很多很多人可能也会有的理论，我只是假设女性使用“我们”这个词的频率会比男性高。
No, there was no difference. Well, at least men will use eye words a lot more than women because they're much more narcissistic. Actually, women consistently use eye words more. I was thinking, what the hell? And it must be a fluke. So I tried it with other data sets. I kept finding it over and over again. And what about cognitive words?
不，没有什么区别。好吧，至少男性会比女性多用很多“我”字，因为他们更自恋。实际上，女性一直更频繁地使用“我”字。我在想，这到底是怎么回事？这一定是个巧合。所以我用其他数据集试了一下。我一次又一次地发现它。认知词呢？
Well, men, you know, I would assume they use them more. No, women use cognitive words at much higher rates than do men. Articles and prepositions, who knew I had no idea. But men consistently use those more than women. The only thing that I, oh, what about emotion words? Well, obviously, women use emotion words more. No, there's virtually no difference. The only difference were social words, references to other people, you know, friends, man, woman, child, etc.
嗯，男人，你知道，我以为他们用的更多。不，女性使用认知词的频率远高于男性。冠词和介词，谁知道呢，我不知道。但男性一直比女性使用得更多。我唯一想到的，哦，情绪词呢？嗯，很明显，女性更多地使用情绪词。不，几乎没有区别。唯一的区别是社交词，对其他人的引用，你知道，朋友、男人、女人、孩子等。
Women use social words at much higher rate, and that's the only one I got right. And I should tell you when I've given tests to people all over the world and ask them who uses these different types of words more men or women, everybody makes the same mistakes that I did. although nowadays people are getting a little bit more sophisticated. But what's happening is the words that I had discovered are called function words. And these are words that don't have a fixed meaning. So she means one thing in one context, but in another context it's referring to another woman. V versus A, V refers to something that you and I both know what it is. When I talk about the table, somehow we've been referenced in our conversation before.
女性使用社交词的频率要高得多，这是我唯一猜对的一个。我应该告诉你，当我给世界各地的人们做测试并问他们谁更经常使用这些不同类型的词，是男人还是女人时，每个人都犯了我所犯的同样的错误。虽然现在人们变得越来越sophisticated（成熟/老练）。但发生的事情是我发现的词被称为功能词。这些是没有固定含义的词。所以在一种语境下，它意味着一件事，但在另一种语境下，它指的是另一个女人。V 与 A，V 指的是你和我都知道它是什么的东西。当我谈到桌子时，不知何故我们在之前的对话中提到过它。
If not, we say a table, my table, that table, et cetera. And these words are interesting because they're processing the brain differently, and they're heavily, heavily psychological. They're related to, as I suggested, depression. They're related to telling the truth versus lying. They're related to relative status. They're related to, you can get a sense of how long the two people have known one another. It tells us about their personality and much, much more.
如果没有，我们会说一个桌子、我的桌子、那个桌子等等。这些词很有趣，因为它们在大脑中的处理方式不同，而且它们具有极强的心理学属性。正如我所暗示的，它们与抑郁有关。它们与说真话还是说谎有关。它们与相对地位有关。它们与你可以感受到两个人认识多久有关。它告诉我们关于他们的个性以及更多信息。
So this was where I started to become so excited about how language could be used to understand individuals, but also couples, but also groups. And then I started to become interested in entire societies. And nowadays with social media, we can start to track how a culture is shifting. So, for example, with COVID, this is not going to come as any shock to anybody, but COVID turned our culture upside down. And in some ways, in possibly permanent ways, certainly put us on a different cultural track. And we can see this through the analysis of Twitter or Reddit or other social media data sets, that when an entire culture is anxious, the entire culture starts using eye words at higher rates. They start using anxiety worth of higher rates. One other thing that I think people will be interested in, working with something like Reddit,
所以这就是我开始对如何利用语言来了解个人、夫妇以及群体产生极大兴趣的地方。然后我开始对整个社会产生兴趣。如今有了社交媒体，我们就可以开始追踪文化是如何转变的。例如，对于新冠疫情，这对任何人来说都不会感到震惊，但新冠疫情把我们的文化颠覆了。在某些方面，可能是以永久的方式，肯定把我们带上了一条不同的文化轨道。我们可以通过分析推特、红迪网或其他社交媒体数据集看到这一点，当整个文化感到焦虑时，整个文化开始以更高的频率使用“我”这个词。他们开始以更高的频率使用与焦虑相关的词汇。我认为人们会感兴趣的另一件事是，通过像红迪网这样的平台，
we're able to download hundreds of thousands of Reddit posts, or we could easily do it up until about a year ago, but we can still do it in other ways now. Working with one of my students, Saras Araraj, what we started to do was to look at how do people behave when they are going through a breakup. And, you know, the ways that we study relationships in psychology historically has been, you know, five people who've had a breakup, you give them a questionnaire, tell me what it was like. Come on, this is a questionnaire. People are constructing stories. What's happening when they're going through a breakup? Well, if you're lucky doing a big study, you know, a few people in your group will have a breakup and you can study them a little bit.
我们能够下载数十万条红迪网帖子，或者直到大约一年前我们都可以轻松做到这一点，但现在我们仍然可以通过其他方式做到这一点。通过与我的学生萨拉斯·阿拉拉杰合作，我们开始研究人们在经历分手时会有怎样的行为。你知道，在心理学中历史上研究关系的方式是，你知道，找五个经历过分手的人，你给他们一份问卷，告诉我那是什么感觉。拜托，这是一份问卷。人们在构建故事。他们在经历分手时究竟发生了什么？好吧，如果你幸运的话，做一个大型研究，你知道，你组里的几个人会经历分手，你可以对他们进行一点研究。
You give them questionnaire. But I don't find it. find that very compelling research. I want to capture a large group of people going through breakup, and I want to track them every day of their lives from before to after. So with social media, I can't do every day of their lives, but I can go to, one of the subredits is breakups. And people go there, and the average person who goes to breakups will post once about their breakup, sometimes asking for advice, sometimes just venting.
你给他们问卷。但我并没有发现这种研究很有吸引力。我想捕捉经历分手的庞大群体，我想追踪他们生前生后的每一天。所以有了社交媒体，我无法做到他们生活的每一天，但可以去其中一个子版块，也就是分手版块。人们去那里，去分手版块的普通人通常会发布一次关于他们分手的帖子，有时寻求建议，有时只是发泄。
So what we did in our study was we went to the breakup subreddit and downloaded everybody who posted at least once. And then to be in our survey or our study, we never actually many of these people. Reddit is it's anonymous. But what we would do is if a person had posted at least a month before somewhere on Reddit and they had posted at least once or twice in a month afterwards somewhere they were eligible to be in our study and our our admissions were a little bit more
所以在我们的研究中，我们去了分手的子版块，下载了所有至少发过一次帖子的人。然后为了进入我们的调查或研究，我们实际上从未见过许多这样的人。红迪网是匿名的。但我们会做的是，如果一个人在红迪网上的某个地方至少在一个月前发过帖子，并且在一个月后的某个地方至少发过一两次帖子，他们就有资格参加我们的研究，我们的准入条件更加
stringent than that we ended up getting about six to eight thousand people and imagine now we go when we find when they make their very first post the average person makes their very first post in the breakup subreddit, typically within two weeks of their breakup. And then what we do is we go and look at all of their posts up to a year before the breakup and to one year after the breakup. And they're posting in all sorts of things. The average person doesn't post very many times in the breakup subreddit. And in fact, we pull out all of their posts dealing with relationships.
严格，最终我们得到了大约六到八千人。现在想象一下，当我们去寻找他们发布第一条帖子的时间时，普通人在分手子版块发布第一条帖子通常是在分手后两周内。然后我们要做的是，去看他们分手前一年到分手后一年之间的所有帖子。他们在各种事情上发帖。普通人在分手子版块发帖的次数并不多。事实上，我们提取了他们所有涉及关系的帖子。
So these are, they're doing Ask Reddit. They're into photography or jokes or what. It doesn't matter to us. We get all of their posts and comments. And the average person, we had over 100 posts and comments in that year before and afters. Meaning we are capturing their lives and their interactions with people that they're not even telling that they're having to break up. Does their writing or thinking change? And it does.
所以这些是，他们在做问卷求助。他们喜欢摄影、笑话什么的。这对我们来说不重要。我们获取了他们所有的帖子和评论。在前后那一年里，普通人有100多条帖子和评论。这意味着我们正在捕捉他们的生活以及他们甚至没有告诉别人他们正在经历分手的那些人的互动。他们的写作或思维改变了吗？确实改变了。
And in fact, we see signs of this breakup that their language starts changing at least three months before the breakup. So you can predict that they're going to break up, right? That's right. Not very well. I'll be honest with you. But what I love about it is that about 75, 77 percent of the people got dumped by their girlfriend or boyfriend. And when they write, they say, this came out of nowhere. it didn't come out of nowhere.
事实上，我们看到了这种分手的迹象，他们的语言在分手前至少三个月就开始发生变化。所以你可以预测他们会分手，对吗？没错。说实话，预测得不是很好。但我喜欢的是，大约75%到77%的人是被他们的女朋友或男朋友甩了。当他们写作时，他们说，这真是突如其来。其实并非突如其来。
There were signals, and that person was broadcasting these signals. And if it got closer and closer to breakup, we saw changes in their thinking, changes in their emotional state, et cetera. And then we could see how long the breakup affects people. And the average person you see really significant effects in terms of their thinking and emotions for six months afterwards. The breakup came away with a much deeper appreciation of how a breakup really messes people up. And you can read it.
有信号，那个人一直在发出这些信号。随着离分手越来越近，我们看到了他们思维的变化、情绪状态的变化等等。然后我们可以看到分手对人们影响多长时间。你会发现，普通人在分手后长达六个月的时间里，在思维和情绪方面会受到非常显著的影响。分手让我对分手如何真正搞砸一个人有了更深的理解。你可以读到它。
They think much less logically. They are disoriented. They are really under a huge amount of stress. And, you know, most employees or employers are not going to say, oh, oh, you've had a breakup. Yeah, take a week off. They never think about that, but the reality is they probably should. Anyway, so we've been using this in all sorts of ways to start to get a sense of how can we measure the effects of a breakup or taking a psychedelic drug or COVID or other events, you know, everything from Black Lives Matter, etc. how can we now use this to get a sense of how individuals and groups change?
他们的逻辑性明显降低。他们感到迷茫。他们确实承受着巨大的压力。而且，你知道，大多数员工或雇主不会说，哦，哦，你分手了。好吧，休假一周吧。他们从来没有考虑过这一点，但现实是他们可能应该这么做。无论如何，我们一直以各种方式使用它来了解我们如何衡量分手、服用致幻剂、新冠疫情或其他事件的影响，你知道，从黑命贵等等一切事物，我们现在如何利用这一点来了解个人和群体是如何改变的？
Well, I just want to ask you one last question. You've studied what we can learn about politicians by analyzing their word use. And given that we're in the middle of a political season right now, I'm just wondering, what have you found? Are you looking at current candidates? And if so, what are you learning from their choice of words? And can you predict what the outcome of the election might be, based on those words.
好吧，我只想问你最后一个问题。你研究了通过分析政客使用的词汇我们可以了解他们什么。鉴于我们现在正处于政治竞选的中期，我只是想知道，你发现了什么？你在关注当前的候选人吗？如果是这样，你从他们的词语选择中学到了什么？你能根据这些词汇预测选举结果吗？
So I have never been able to predict who's going to win based on words. But I can tell you what kind of, you know, how that candidate thinks. And, you know, the reality is we have two likely candidates and we already know how they think. And they think probably in ways that you would imagine. It's quite interesting. One of the two candidates uses I all the time. And some people think that's narcissism. Well, it can be narcissism, but it's also insecurity.
所以我从来没有能够根据字眼预测谁会赢。但我可以告诉你那种，你知道，那个候选人是如何思考的。你知道，现实是我们有两个可能的候选人，我们已经知道他们是怎么想的。他们的想法可能正如你所想象的那样。这非常有趣。其中一位候选人一直使用“我”。有些人认为这是自恋。嗯，这可能是自恋，但这也是不安全感。
And the one who uses eye words at very, very high rates, more than any previous president, of course, is Donald Trump. And he's been using it at particularly high rates over the last couple of months. but he always had. Another dimension that we always look at is something that we call analytic thinking. Analytic thinking is really kind of interesting. It's this goofball algorithm that we came up with, and it's essentially, if you come right down to it, people who use a high rate of nouns and a low rate of verbs, or another way to think about it, high rates of articles and prepositions and low rate,
而以非常非常高的频率使用“我”这个词的那个候选人，比以往任何总统都多，当然就是唐纳德·特朗普。在过去的几个月里，他一直以特别高的频率使用它，但他一直都这样。我们总是关注的另一个维度是我们称之为分析性思维的东西。分析性思维其实挺有意思的。这是我们想出的一个笨拙的算法，从根本上说，如果你归结到底，就是那些高频使用名词和低频使用动词的人，或者换个角度想，高频使用冠词和介词而低频使用
rates of pronouns. And people who are high in this analytic thinking, looking at their admissions essays, they do much better at university than people who are low rate, lower at analytic thinking. It's correlated with IQ, et cetera. And it's essentially a marker of formal logical analytic thinking. Donald Stratt, not surprisingly, is the lowest of any president ever in terms of the of analytic thinking. And Biden's kind of there in the middle. He's not high, but he's not extremely low. In terms of clout, this is another measure that we have, which is this sense of
代词的人。在分析性思维方面得分很高的人，看他们的入学申请论文，他们在大学里的表现比分析性思维得分低的人要好得多。它与智商等相关。它本质上是形式逻辑分析思维的一个标志。毫不奇怪，唐纳德·特朗普在分析性思维方面是有史以来所有总统中最低的。拜登则处于中间位置。他既不算高，但也不是极低。就影响力（clout）而言，这是我们的另一个衡量标准，也就是那种
certainty and conveying, you know, that they, that they are certain of what they're saying. both Biden and Trump are high. Trump is again highest, and he's one of the highest ever. Obama was very high in cloud also. In fact, if there's anything a really interesting project that one of my former students, Kayla Jordan did and Ryan Boyd's been involved in all these studies as well, was looking at the history of U.S. presidents, but also prime ministers in the U.K., and Canada as well.
确定性以及传达，你知道，他们，他们对他们所说的话确信不疑。拜登和特朗普都很高。特朗普再次最高，他是最高的人之一。奥巴马在影响力方面也很高。事实上，如果有什么的话，我的前学生凯拉·约旦（Kayla Jordan）做了一个非常有趣的项目，瑞恩·博伊德（Ryan Boyd）也参与了所有这些研究，那就是研究美国总统的历史，还有英国和加拿大的首相。
And ever since about 1910 or so, we have been electing presidents who are higher and higher in cloud, that is more and more certainty, with a corresponding drop in analytic, logical thinking. And I think what's happening is we, the people, like people who convey things in a very simple way with absolute authority, which, hey, people, that's not a very smart way to pick a leader. Because what we're picking are people who often are not that bright, but they're certain, and that's what we like. Yeah. And, you know, it's the Cheetos theory of elections, which is if it tastes good and it's
大约从1910年左右开始，我们选出的总统在影响力上越来越高，也就是说确定性越来越高，而分析性、逻辑性思维则相应下降。我认为发生的情况是，我们大众喜欢那些以绝对权威用非常简单的方式传达事情的人，这，嘿，人们，这不是挑选领导人的一个非常明智的方式。因为我们挑选的往往是不那么聪明但很确信的人，而这正是我们喜欢的。是的。而且，你知道，这就是选举的奇多理论，也就是如果它尝起来很好而且
crunchy, of course it's, of course we like it. And that's how, that's how I think we often, we often vote. And by the way, Democrats, Democratic candidates have been shifting this way, just have Republican candidates. It's because we, the populace, and the Brits, it's, we see the same, even though they selected prime minister differently. And we see the same thing in Canada as well. This increase in certainty and decrease in logical analytical. Thank you. Well, Dr. Pennebaker, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been really interesting.
脆脆的，当然它是，当然我们喜欢它。这就是我认为我们经常，我们经常投票的方式。顺便说一句，民主党人，民主党候选人一直在向这个方向转变，就像共和党候选人一样。这是因为我们民众和英国人，我们看到了同样的现象，尽管他们选择首相的方式不同。我们在加拿大也看到了同样的现象。这种确定性的增加和逻辑分析的减少。谢谢。好吧，彭尼贝克博士，我要感谢您今天能来参加。这真的很有趣。
We could have gone on and on, but I think we're out of time here, so thank you again. I've enjoyed it. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyian. Thank you for listening. The American Psychological Association,
我们本来可以一直聊下去，但我想我们的时间到了，所以再次谢谢你。我很享受。您可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或在苹果、Spotify、YouTube 或您获取播客的任何地方找到往期的《心理学谈话》节目。如果您喜欢您所听到的，请订阅并给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有评论或想法，您可以发送电子邮件至 Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·孔迪扬（Chris Kondyian）。感谢您的收听。美国心理学协会，
I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。